have I told you I love you yes dad you
told me like a billion times
honey you please come down here done
something this happened you can't go in
there
I love my family I failed to protect
them I'm sorry doctor Kersey nothing yet
so there's nothing that I can do is that
what you're saying
can I have faith have faith work out for
them
if a man really wants to protect courts
his
he has to do is for himself the men who
did it or out there we're gonna hunt
them down
one by one
train set up the dark for clothes oh
yeah Joey right yeah
you're not gonna kill me no Jack is
we got a call it's from crossfire yeah
you said next time I think we'll be in
the lake
you are gonna be all right I promise
you're not a cop somebody has to
everybody's watching this viral video is
this dude right foot taking the law into
his own hand a hero keeps playing
but is it wrong you're cocked locked and
ready to work I'll say someone took my
wife
is going to pay
you look much better getting out
socializing mm not so much
well whatever you're doing keep it up
okay I will
you
you